Hey, David, will Republicans support an election
day, an election delay, rather, if Donald
Trump is definitely going to lose?
So this is an interesting question because
it first assumes that Republicans or Trump
ists might come to the conclusion that Trump
definitely is going to lose.
I don't think the average Trump ist is going
to believe that going into November.
In other words, the average Trump ist no matter
what.
If Trump says he's doing well in the polls,
which he's been saying, even though he's not.
They will believe Trump has a chance.
So in practice, I don't think this scenario
is going to come up because you're not going
to convince the vast majority of Trump ists
that Trump is is going to lose.
Let's imagine you did.
Would they then support an election delay
if Trump wanted it?
Absolutely.
If there's one thing we've learned during
this presidency, it's that anything Trump
wants, his followers want.
If it's the authoritarian deployment of paramilitaries
with no badges and unmarked vans to Portland
and Chicago and wherever, even if they thought
they were small government, conservative libertarians
or whatever, up until that they're supporting
it, no question about it.
When it's trump against vote by mail, they're
against vote by mail.
Trump comes out, as he did last week or the
week before and says in Florida, it's safe
and everybody should vote by mail.
They immediately fall in line and they say,
yes, yes, everybody should be voting by mail
because Donald Trump said so.
So if Donald Trump were to Trump has floated
it.
He's not said we need to delay, but he's floated
And he said we might not know the results
for weeks or years.
He even said, which is absolutely ridiculous.
If Trump actually came out and said, I believe
we should delay the election to whatever date,
it would be crazy, right.
There'd be no legal basis for it.
Of course, a huge portion of his followers
will fall in line because they fall in line
with absolutely anything that he says.
We have to make sure that we start voting
now.
I mean, there are states wherein I think,
is it two and a half weeks or three weeks?
Early voting, absentee ballots start.
We have to overwhelm the vote so that it's
not close.
And we need to just remember that a federal
election has never been delayed.
There have never been delays to presidential
elections.
His followers are liable to support absolutely
anything that he wants.
Well, we have to make sure we do is to vote,
participate.
Keep the pressure on as far as the post office.
Keep the pressure on as far as vote by mail.
And none of this stuff is really going to
become an issue.
And I'm not sure I understand why I'm getting
so many questions like will Republicans support
delaying the election?
Or will the military be required to remove
Donald Trump?
I get it.
I understand why that's going on.
And it's because many of you are willing to
crawl over broken glass to vote in November
one way or the other by mail or in person,
because you see the importance of removing
Donald Trump.
I get it.
I do not believe it's actually going to come
to that.
I do not believe we are going to have any
serious possibility of an election delay.
I do not believe that if Donald Trump loses,
the military will be required to remove him.
I do not believe it.
These could be famous last words.
I will eat my hat if it ends up working out
that way in November into January.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or a patron
at Patrie on dot com slash David Pakman show.
I will see you on the bonus show.